but first we begin this morning with the
dangerous and deadly heat gripping
nearly more than half the nation tens of
millions are set to broil in
record-setting high temperatures this
weekend with heat advisories or warnings
in effect from the Midwest to much of
the East Coast that coupled with high
humidity and the heat index will exceed
100 degrees here in New York as well as
other major cities the heat wave has
already blamed for at least six deaths
the extreme weather is testing power
companies as they work to keep air
conditioners and mass transit systems
working last night in New York tens of
thousands of subway riders were left
trapped on sweltering platforms after a
computer system failure it is unclear if
the weather was to blame but it was just
part of the city that was affected the
New York triathlon has been canceled as
of countless outdoor music festivals and
parties now to another major city
Natalie Brand has more from a hot and
steamy Washington this morning Natalie
good morning to you good morning to you
Jeff and Michelle well one reason why
city leaders across the East Coast are
so worried about this this heat wave is
hitting during the weekend people want
to be outdoors enjoying their Saturday
visitors to DC will be out and about
taking in the history of this city but
the message to stress this morning take
this heat seriously in the nation's
capital the heat is usually inside the
chambers of Congress this weekend it's
outside so hot the mayor of DC activated
a heat emergency plan dr. Chris
Rodriguez is the district's director of
Homeland Security and Emergency
Management Agency
he says officials will be monitoring the
dangerous temperatures from this
Emergency Operations Center this is
going to be one of the most severe heat
events that we've had in the last
several years and so again we are we are
watching for the effects of heat stroke
and heat exhaustion more than 150
million people are expected to feel the
first major heat wave of the year which
has the potential to break daily records
while Midwestern cities like Milwaukee
and Chicago will be affected the East
Coast is expected to take the brunt of
it the message I want to keep getting
crossed all New Yorkers is take this
weather seriously temperatures are
expected to range from the mid 90s to
the triple digits with the heat index
making it feel as hot as a hundred to a
hundred and fifteen degrees you go out
and you feel like you're hitting a wall
of heat and you feel like you're in an
oven the whole time so yeah it's pretty
brutal I feel overwhelmed from the heat
that's it's unbearable really not only
uncomfortable but potentially
life-threatening with at least six
deaths already reported including 32
year old former New York Giants
linebacker who died Thursday of apparent
heatstroke experts warned that the heat
can really be a silent killer doctors
urging you to watch out for those
symptoms of heat illness they include of
course headache dizziness muscle
cramping nausea and another important
sign to look for a lack of sweating
Alain all right Natalie good information
thank you for more on the extreme heat
let's turn to meteorologist Jeff Baer
Adelie Jeff good morning good morning
Elaine and good morning everybody this
is a huge heat wave covering about a
hundred and fifty plus million people
across the eastern two-thirds of the
country we may break two dozen records
they're in jeopardy as we head through
the weekend
it's not just the heat it's definitely
the humidity this time humidity is
surging to the north across the Great
Lakes and into the Northeast around this
area of high pressure combining with hot
temperatures near 104 feels like
temperatures between a hundred and 115
degrees this is the way it looks during
the day today st. Louis feels like
temperature 109 Detroit 111 Baltimore
114 and during the day tomorrow of the
same Louisville 103 111 in Richmond 111
in Baltimore still hot in st. Louis 108
degrees we zoom in on the Northeast
because this is where we're gonna see
some of the hottest temperatures today
and tomorrow it's 100 in New York today
feels like 113 tomorrow it feels like
109 in New York almost up to 115 is the
feels-like temperature during the day
but here's the good news
you probably want relief and it's coming
we're gonna see how big
lip in the jet stream as we head into
early next week and this is gonna feel
oh so good as we head into Monday
Tuesday and Wednesday ooh
so glad to hear that just the duration
of this too it sees both these days yeah
and people really need to take care
because I think it couldn't sneak up on
people and hydrating is so important
like Natalie was talking about know
those signs of heat stress heat stroke
because it really can't say with
neighbors if you meet anybody vulnerable
elderly young children etc very easy to
get dehydrated thank you